[Applaus]
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport rapport
dem sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers heute zu gast marathonläufer
le mans thema welche areale herzlich
willkommen
danke wie läuft das bei dir derzeit mit
der vorbereitung wie geht es dir meine
vorbereitung ist schon jetzt langsam
wieder besser und schon seit letzter
woche wieder mit trainings normal
angefangen
und ja es war wirklich eine schwierige
zeit wegen corona das ist auch eine
große geschichte aber jedes schon meine
volker sondern zukunft olympia und dann
ist schon okay das ist durchaus
optimistisch in die zukunft du hast auch
angesprochen dass die vorbereitung wegen
corona schwierig war
was war denn so schwierig diese krone
geschichte sportler und für mich
persönlich ist wirklich es ist eine
schwierige zeit gewesen weil ich schon
ich war schon zweimal trainingslager
gewissen und auch schon gut vorbereitet
und dann mein trainings war ganz toll um
die war auch persönlich gut in form und
dann zweimal abgesagt und dann nochmal
bin zurück nach hause gekommen und dann
sie haben abgesagt wahnsinn wie schwer
ist und dann die moral
das ist unglaublich aber jetzt endlich
gott sei dank schon die krone ist auch
ein bisschen ruhiger geworden und auch
gerade lehrer auch jedes veranstaltung
bisher nach startplatz schon angefangen
das ist auch eine gute blickt und das
ist eine gute motivation
das heißt die großen herausforderungen
die verschiebungen das schwieriger
planen hat anscheinend für dich dazu
geführt dass du dass du eben diesen
herausforderungen gestellt was aber der
blick in die zukunft das auch schon
gesagt es kennen
mehr veranstaltungen stattfinden das
heißt es gibt auch bald wieder
hoffentlich die gewohnten marathonläufe
im hinblick auf youtube was steht da
noch alles an bis drücke welche läufe
hast du denn noch alle geplant die
hoffentlich auch stattfinden können ich
hoffe schon auch im koffer verschiedenen
plan und habe gehört auch es gibt in
meinen marathon und mein plan ist jetzt
vor dem olympia einen schnelleren
marathon probieren und auch wenn es
möglich und dann auch natürlich wenig
sei alles gutgeht zehn kilometer und
dann ist olympia
du bist ja auch schon so gut wie
qualifiziert was das limit für olympia
für drucker schon erbracht der
qualifikation ist also so gut wie
fixiert da kann nur noch schwer etwas
passieren 2016 hat das knapp nicht
gereicht da hast du dich knapp oder
nicht qualifiziert wie geht das jetzt
damit dass du kurz vor deinem ersten
olympischen spielen stehst und das für
österreich ja es 2006 ins war wirklich
wenig denke ich denke auch okay was habe
ich gehabt und dann was war mein fehler
und so und olympia es ist schon wichtig
und ich habe schon einen große chance
gehabt ihn 2006 ist um olympia
zum teilnehmen rio und aber leider haben
nichts geschafft und aber ein jahr
vorher 2000 funktion war im rio bin
schon hreo marathon gelaufen und dann
die seite war ganz knapp das männer war
es ist wirklich andere geschickte ich
habe mit einen kenianer kollege sind
unauffällig sind gestritten stehen
geblieben
leider bin selber schuld auch ja habe
deswegen habe er nichts geschafft und ja
aber es sogar jedes in neue motivation
und auch neue sachen ist auch wichtig
für mich persönlich bin neugierig auch
ich bin auch wirklich sehr motivation
tokio 21 laufen und er in tokio wird
einen sehr warmen marathon geben
höchstwahrscheinlich das heißt die
bedingungen sind schwierig für
marathonläufer wie fühlst du dich wenn
wenn es eher hohe luftfeuchtigkeit hat
und eher warm ist wie geht es dir da
wenn du die 42 kilometer absolvieren
muss warm wenn es so warm ist für mich
keine spiele rolle ist ich habe schon
ein bisschen erfahrung
deswegen bieten auch in 2015 rio habe
einen test auch gehabt und ich habe
überhaupt kein problem
es ist nicht so einfach aber ist schon
okay ich kann das schaffen es ist das
ist auch für mich eine gute chance so
war ließ und für meine person ist kein
problem was du alles schaffst das hast
du auch schon oft bewiesen in deiner
karriere mit medaillen bei
europameisterschaften und auch mit
wahnsinnigen leistungen bei den ring for
life world runs wo du schon dreimal über
70 kilometer einmal sogar über 80
kilometer gelaufen bist also für einen
normalen menschen kaum vorstellbar
du bist ursprünglich aus äthiopien und
bis 2015 staatsbürger österreichischer
staatsbürger geworden
fangen wir mit ein bisschen mit mit
einer geschichte auch viel viel weiter
an als er noch ein kind war es ich habe
hier stehen dass du als kind in die
schule laufen muss das wie kann man sich
das vorstellen
ja sport ist laufen ist für mich und
aber für auch alle äthiopischen kindern
meine dürfe das ist normal und weil es
von schule bis zu hause schon hat
kilometer laufen immer jeden tag hat
kilometern zurück ist sexy zusammen
montag bis freitag um das bedeutet auch
man muss auch bisschen früher dort
seinen der schule sonst bekommst du
strafen und deswegen wie tragen auch
alle sachen mit und dann ja das hat bis
dann auch geholfen
also war schon ein gutes training im
kindheits alter aber man hat
wahrscheinlich trotzdem schnell erkannt
dass du auch talent hast du warst
nämlich auch in äthiopien militär
sportler das heißt dass du dich auf den
sport konzentrieren kannst aber ich gehe
mal davon aus die dichte der leistung
ist dort enorm hoch wie kann man sich
das ungefähr vorstellen in meine kinder
etappen auch viele sachen gemacht und
dann beim laufen in solchen sachen und
ich glaube das hat mich bisher geholfen
aber in der schule wie habe nach begann
für gehabt in pause seit aber laufen
profi ich habe ein bisschen zu spät
angefangen
ich habe schon auch ein verein gehabt
nichts mehr da in drei oder zwei verein
gehabt und ändere ich habe schon auch
war beim militär vereinen äthiopien und
ja
ich sag auch ist bis an talent sein muss
man habe ein solches kannst du nicht
schaffen das ist auch bis ein schweres
ist nicht so leicht um einen verein zu
finden
das heißt man muss wirklich auch gut
sein sonst bekommt dann auch gar nicht
die möglichkeit du bist auch als
sportler in äthopien schon international
gereist auf wettkämpfe und hat sich dann
aber 2013 entschieden nicht mehr
zurückzukehren sondern zu flüchten was
war denn der grund wie war die zeit
damals für dich was ich ja nicht nicht
einfach für dich oder ja es ist die
grund war ich hab schon wie gesagt seit
2000 erstmals in 2011 nach europa
geflogen schon ich habe mein erster
wettkampf 2011 wenn wähler sieht die
marathon gehabt und danach bin ich schon
auch nach italien aber auch in italien
anderer wettkampf gehabt und rotterdam
und noch in beginnen so aber vorher bin
ich schon auch mehrere male geflogen ich
habe von mehreren bekannten gehabt wie
gesagt meine verein war einem militär
verein und ich habe schon wirklich immer
probleme gehabt mit solchen geschichte
aber damals habe nie geplant
okay das ist österreich ist meine zweite
heimat nie in meiner kopf gehabt mein
ziel und mein traum ist schon ok ich
muss gut trainieren gut vorbereiten muss
eine gute leistung bringen das war meine
meinem ziel in meiner kopf und aber so
verkaufen dass diese problem ist mehr
und mehr geworden dann habe gesagt 2013
nahe ich kann nicht mehr fliegen nach
hitler bashung es ist gefährlich und ich
habe vorher viele strafe gehabt beim
militär und solchen sachen dann aber
gedacht nein ich bleibe da und dann
versuche anderer leben ist laufen ist
nicht mein
sachen weil haben alles probiert und
halle gegeben aber ist immer sorgen und
dann aber hier entschieden sondern hier
zu bleiben
ich habe nämlich auch damals als du dann
in österreich entdeckte wurde es dann
lauf talent entdeckt wurde und wie die
ganze zeit war das dann einen asylantrag
gestellt der ist auch positiv
beantwortet worden 2014 und eben 2015
bist du eingebürgert worden
wie war deine wahrnehmung von dieser
zeit wie hast du dich damals in
österreich gefühlt es ist laufen ist
bedeutet für mich ganz anders laufen ist
für mich wie leben ohne sport film ist
das leben ist es langweilig und sie war
schon zum beispiel in transfer erst das
mal 2030 ist wirklich helfen fast jeden
tag trainiert aber es ist nichts
professional fast jeden tag gebissen
das mag für mich auch ruhig in meiner
kopfweh nicht ein training habe oder
wenn die nicht trainiert dabei und dann
ist für mich ist es langweilig ganzen
tag
dann ist sie schon 2014 in asyl am
krippenstein ich habe schon auch fast
jeden tag trainiert und da hat schon
auch paar kontakt auch mit verschiedenen
leute genau verschiedenen wettkampf
kleinen wettkampf gelaufen hatten
gewonnen
und vielleicht das hat geholfen
aber wisst wie hast du dich gefühlt hat
diese ganze zeit zu erleben diesen
prozess durch zu machen was du immer
schon so positiv dass du gesagt hast
auch das wird vorübergehen ich schaffe
das
oder hast du das erst in dieser zeit
gelernt ja wie gesagt sport dieses
laufes ist meinen wie sie leben schon
ich denke in eine seite schon okay
geschäft aber ohne trend für mich ist
lebenslang wähle dann ist schon ich habe
schon mein trainings weiter trainiert
und dann hat auch viel geholfen so
sport dies für mich positiv energie
markt auch denken positiv machte mich
ausruhen so und sport bedeute dass
mehrere in sachen für mich und du hast
damit auch eine große strahl wirkung das
heißt man sieht das was du geleistet
hast und welchem weg zugegangen ist der
vorstand der österreichischen e
türkischen gesellschaft und des
typischen kulturzentrums habe dich 2009
10 zum mann des jahres ernannt was
bedeutet dir so eine ernennung sein
preis ja gott sei dank ich bin schon
wirklich ein glücklicher mensch und
meine sportsachen hat auch viel geholfen
schon auch gut funktioniert und ist
natürlich in eine seite auch man muss
auch sehr fleißig sein es ist nicht so
einfach es gibt auch mehrere schwere
seite ich mache mein sport fast jeden
tag und ich habe auch keine ahnung wie
zum beispiel wenn es so winter ist bei
uns in idiotisch und niemals kalt und
haben auch hier - schnee gesehen mein
leben und ok hab schon solche sachen
auch geschafft und sie zusammen hat
geholfen denn das ist das ist eine
richtige weg für mich hat viel geholfen
und du bekommst auch die anerkennung und
auch der sportliche erfolg funktioniert
du hast eben für österreich auch schon
eine europameisterschaft bronze medaille
gewonnen nämlich mit dem team in berlin
was bedeutet das für dich so eine
medaille für österreich zu gewinnen
2.000 aktien europameisterschaft in
berlin war unglaublich das ist für mich
eine große überraschung das ist auch
eine große geschenk von lieber gott bin
ich sagen meine glaube das ist meine
erste leben und reich
eine zweite heimat österreich und bin
wirklich sehr sehr glücklich mensch und
das war unglaublich und ich denke immer
wahnsinn das ist die geht's das uns so
ja dass sie das war unglaublich
situation wie sehr kommt auch stolz in
solchen momenten auf zu wissen was du
erlebt hast und dann am podium zu stehen
und die medaille zu bekommen
bist du da auch dann richtig stolz auf
die leistung gewesen bis sie natürlich
wahrnehmen haben so solchen erfolgreich
raten muss auch stolz sein das ist auch
das hilft da auch zum beispiel okay was
gar nicht so tun zukunft das hilft auch
das ist eine positive energie und dann
ist auch und dann nachher okay es ist
das ist eine gute nachricht dann okay
jetzt habe schon das gemacht und das ist
auch gut gegangen
was ist der nächste schrieb das ist für
mich wäre ist auch eine gute nachricht
wenn man fleißig trainiert und oder
arbeit das ist alles ist möglich sind
ist möglich und dann ja das war eine
guter weg für mich das heißt wenn man
hart arbeitet diszipliniert ist sein
bestes gibt dann ist alles reicht es
meist gehen hast du angetreten du bist
dann auch 2009 10 wie du das olympia
limit gelaufen bist auch
österreichischen rekord gelaufen das
heißt noch nie ist vorher jemand
schneller den marathon in österreich
oder für österreich gelaufen
welchen stellenwert hat so ein rekord
für dich das bad weiter geschickt wenn
er sich die marathon 2009 10 war ich
unglaublich einen schönen atmosphäre
unglaubliche stimmung und so und ja für
mich war es auch ein zweiter schritt
neue österreich eine rekord es war
wirklich auch unglaubliche
geschickter in meine sportkarriere aber
insgesamt ist 2009 10 war wenn er sie
die marathon einen unglaublich geschickt
er für mich den rekord hat nämlich der
zwischenzeit dein kollege peter herzig
unterboten aber du hast schon
angekündigt so möchtest natürlich noch
einmal schneller sein betreuer sagt 207
das ist möglich ist das dein ziel 207 zu
laufen
genau mein ziel ist wenn es gutgeht
minister aus meinem plan zukommt 2827
aber ist möglich auch unter 24 werden
kann sein aber wie gesagt er ist man
muss auch fleißig trainieren man muss
auch gesund sein man muss auch ganz fit
sein dann ist wenn man so gut
vorbereitet und viel diszipliniert und
dann ist alles ist möglich nichts ist
unmöglich aber es dauert zeit natürlich
es ist nicht so wie heute morgen sport
bisschen geduld und dann ist es an reich
das sport auf jeden fall eine schule für
die geduld es geht nicht von heute auf
morgen das heißt genau sagt du bist dann
auch zum bundesheer gekommen und bis
jetzt eben heeressportler wie war die
grundausbildung für dich war das eine
neue erfahrung die grundausbildung beim
bundesheer zu machen ja grundausbildung
war für mich unglaublich das ist auch
andere geschichten meine leben
die sprache ist es noch für mich nicht
so einfach aber beim grundausbildung der
wiesn an meist ein r sprichst auch
bisschen der legt und wahnsinn ist es
für mich war aber gott sei dank das ist
eine auch lebenserfahrung
das ist was ich denke wenn man probiert
etwas ist egal
die sprache oder wenn ich schwer ist ist
alles ist möglich aber
never give up probieren immer suchen und
positiv denken und nicht nein ich kann
ich muss sagen ich kann aber es dauert
alles ist möglich gott sei dank bei mir
war auch beim anfang bissig wirkt die
sprache und verstehen zum antworten so
und aber hab schon geschafft gott sei
dank ich bin schon zufrieden bin stolz
auf mich auch natürlich und bundesheer
ist sehr wichtig für mich das ist mein
leben ist damit der sport als profi
ausüben kannst gibt es etwas was du
gelernt hast wo du sagst das habe ich
vorher nicht gewusst und seitdem ich
beim bundesheer bin habe ich das gelernt
egal was das was dir einfällt zum
beispiel beim bundesheer was ich gelernt
habe das ist die wichtigste sache ist
für mich
man muss pünktlich sein auch schneller
und auch bisschen erkämpfen
ich sage ja früher das ist ein bisschen
auch meine erfahrung
nein kann schon das morgen machen aber
beim bundesheer ist nicht so es ist ganz
anderer mann muss es ist muss muss
hoffen dass auch gelernt das ist
pünktlich zum beispiel die seit okay
kann nicht so meine hausaufgaben kann
morgen machen
nein ich muss heute fertig machen und
dann das ist wichtig und das ist auch
für mich eine wichtige erfahrung dass
ich beim bundesheer gelernt habe das
heißt pünktlichkeit diszipliniert und
wirklich auch machen und nicht dahin
schweifen lassen wenn du in die zukunft
schaut was wäre noch ein traum was ist
etwas wovon du träumst oder sagst das
möchte ich unbedingt schaffen
meine träume mein traum ist jetzt bin
schon noch aktiv ist natürlich die
erster schritt ist olympiatest gleich
eine gute leistung bringen und dann ist
es natürlich auch unten
237 laufen und dann ist kommt der
nächste schritt
das heißt auch die ziele werden schritt
für schritt genau geplant gibt es etwas
was du aus äthopien vermisst was es in
österreich nicht gibt was ich vermisst
habe schon konnten mit meiner familie
ich vermisse immer jeden vermisst auch
mit familien so in kontakt ich vermisse
auch wirklich meine mutter meine mutter
ist für mich ich habe keine worte zum
sagen und sie ist für mich alles und sie
hat schon alles gegeben sie hat schon
alles geholt wenn so aber wurde dank sie
ist sie lebte noch und leider mein vater
sei schon ein jahr gestorben und die
vermieter solchen sachen soll es ich
habe schon alles die gefühle
österreichisch mein land und ich habe
alles und ja was soll ist man muss
zufrieden sein
gott sei dank ich habe alles ich schaue
die anderen so ist das aber beans
momentan ist alles okay und aber mit
wally die sachen bisschen 'schon und
soll es ebenso frieden in meinem leben
das ist schön dass er dankbarkeit zu
haben sie auch zu kommunizieren
du hast deine eltern angesprochen du
hattest dort als kind natürlich auch am
bauernhof der eltern viel zu tun auch
die arbeit mit den tieren ist das auch
etwas was dir gefallen hat oder war das
einfach notwendig damit der bauernhof
haushalt gut funktioniert ja bei uns in
europa zum beispiel in meinem dorf das
ist normal das ist eine normale grippe
alle kinder muss auch aufpassen die
tiere und adelt er dann auch zb wie ich
haben
in verschiedenen gemüsen so bei uns gibt
auf mehreren tieren und dann die andere
sie fressen alles und sie machen auch
alles kaputt die kinder müssen auch
alles solche sachen aufpassen natürlich
auch die familien helfen neben der
schule und das ist auch andere
geschickte und java schon ist alles ist
vorbei und ja ich vermisse aus solchen
situationen und jetzt ist es schon
andere leben so ist aber auf jeden fall
einiges gelernt auch aus diesen
erfahrungen du hast es im rahmen unseres
gespräches oft angesprochen diese
dankbarkeit in die zukunft schauen
zufrieden sein
danke auf jeden fall dass du uns diese
einblicke gegeben hast alles gute für
tokio danke danke danke der einladung
auch wir hoffen natürlich viele erfolge
weiter hinter von dir zu hören
danke euch fürs mit dabei sein wir
freuen uns wenn ihr auch beim nächsten
mal wieder beim sport reporter ein klick
zur ein herz und mit dabei sein
bis dann
[Musik]
[Applaus]